but after what seemed like a Long Winter
many of us are happy to have that warm
sunshine back again but too much sun
exposure can put you at risk for skin
cancer 8 news now reporter Victoria Saha
spoke with a Valley dermatologist on
what you and your family should look for
as you get ready for summer
it's a beautiful sunny day here in Las
Vegas and before you head out you're
probably grabbing your son
Oma Monday doctors want to remind you of
how important it is to lather on that
sunscreen before you face the Desert Sun
[Applause]
Fawn in the sun means pools Beach and
lots of time Outdoors but if you aren't
careful you may say goodbye to Summer
with more than just memories people do
go in the pool here a lot to get out of
the Heat and the Sun is attracted to
them being in the water it amplifies the
amount of sun exposure that they get
exposure that could lead to skin cancer
people ask oh can I get a baseline tan
is that going to make me safe and the
answer is no Las Vegas dermatologist Dr
H.L Greenberg says melanoma is the most
aggressive form of skin cancer he shows
us the special tool he uses to screen
his patients basically I would use this
this light and this one here and
actually up top here it looks like you
have what's called a lentigo or Freckle
like growth so that would be normal
though my screening was normal Dr
Greenberg says he finds melanoma in at
least two patients a month if you catch
them early your chance of living is
fantastic the abnormalities could be
obvious but sometimes they aren't and I
thought that she had a cyst on her leg
and I punched a hole into this cyst and
nothing came out the American Cancer
Society says skin cancer is the most
common cancer with 5 million people in
the United States being diagnosed each
year they predict in Nevada 800
residents will be diagnosed with
melanoma this year alone but what makes
us stand out well if you follow our
forecast on a regular basis we live in a
place where there's at least 300 days of
sunshine a year